good afternoon and welcome back to the
orwh 30th anniversary scientific
symposium afternoon session
my name is lisa begg and i'm the program
official for the birch program which had
its 20th anniversary celebration
yesterday
and i've been asked to
cover a few slides from yesterday and
introduced the panel today because all
of them have a birch affiliation
in terms of yesterday there were two
major addresses
one in honor of dr ruth l kirsten
her memorial lectureship which was given
by dr patricia molino
dr molino is a leading
leading mentor
and renowned researcher
with continuous nih funding
over 20 years
and she is also the um has an endowed
chair and is his department chair at
louisiana state university in new
orleans
her talk as well as the other talks
are available on the lab roots platform
from yesterday as well as the nih
videocast archive
the second major address was given by dr
claire sturk
who gave the inaugural
birch legacy of leadership lecture
dr sterk is the president emerita from
from emory university and also created
the emory birch program six years ago
just as she was assuming her presidency
of emory so a busy lady
she covered
mentoring as well as her various career
achievements
and different pathways for young
investigators to consider
in terms of the birch program some of
you may not be familiar with it so i've
been asked to give you just a few brief
slides
the birch program birch stands for
building interdisciplinary research
careers in women's health
it was created in in 2000 so it's had
its 20th anniversary yesterday
it is considered an nih
a mentored career development
institutional grant which means it's
trains more than one
trainee each at any one time
and it has
it focuses in on the health of women and
sex and gender influences
a program was established in 2000 and it
partners across the nih and there's a
subsequent slide which lists our ic
partners
from the onset it focused in on
interdisciplinary mentoring at the time
this was very unusual and we have
continued the focus here and are very
proud to say that we as you can see here
have had representation either as the
grantee institution or the school within
the grantee institution and training
scholars in these areas of medicine
nursing public health social sciences
um
bioengineering behavioral sciences
anthropology and so forth as they relate
to research on the health of women
in terms of accomplishments this slide
actually represents a
a
summary of the research that was
evaluation that was done between 2000
and 2018
there were 88 grants to 44 institutions
during that period of time
and as you can see here on the left
these are the institutes and centers at
nih that have partnered with us over the
20-year period
including the office of aids research
at present we have 22 active birch
programs and if i was able to show you a
map they would represent across the
united states eastern southern midwest
and the western states as well so we're
very proud of that
the program
is funded at approximately 10 million
dollars a year
and the institutes and centers are
contributing funding as well as the orwh
being the v and the majority uh and on
the right side you will see that the
that the uh current recipients um are
the 22 inc
institutions
on the right side
the birch evaluation program was
undertaken
in the run-up for the 20th anniversary
and i would like to acknowledge my two
colleagues dr zinnia tigno and dr
charisse johnstone who have worked on
the evaluation report
in terms of outcomes
84 percent of our scholars during that
18-year period stayed in academia
largely in women's health research and
another 15 percent were in industry and
a very small amount went into government
uh terminal degrees we are very
interested in this as is nih because of
the interest in training not only phd
level scientists but physician
scientists as you can see here about 42
percent of the
birch scholars have an md or a
combination md phd md mph and so forth
and 54 have phd and some of those also
have um additional degrees
uh and you'll see also uh the male to
female ratios here 80 percent of the
birch scholars are women over the
20-year period 20 are men
we're very pleased about recruiting men
as well
in terms of productivity um we were
gratified to find here that our level
grants and these would be r01 grants the
classic r01 brands r21 which is a small
grant innovation
um grant and then r03 which is another
small grant mechanism so 70 of the birch
scholars have had at least one r-level
grant post uh their birch training and
you can see the the range goes up um
more than 10
and many of those with the higher
numbers of grants were part of um very
successful interdisciplinary teams so
there was a synergy there which
increased the grant the number of grants
as well
there was 30 percent of the scholars
went on to achieve individual k grants
and these are career development grants
and then 77 of the scholars received in
addition to the r-level nih grants they
received foundation grants institutional
seed money grants and so forth so again
this is a highly productive group of
scholars and now number over 700.
we were also very pleased um and this is
a relatively new um the phenomena here
is that when the program was was created
in 2000 it was not focused on recruiting
underrepresented minorities but in the
more recent years we have and as you can
see here 20 21
of the scholars recruited between 2015
and 2018 uh fall under the
underrepresented minority uh category
and that's the nih definition that
includes african american
or black pacific islander
the alaska native american indian
as well as hispanic or latina so we're
pleased with this as well there is there
were some of the scholars who declined
to to give their race and ethnicity and
that
of course we accept that in terms of any
research
um in terms of the general uh
preliminary conclusions as you can see
here there's career success
um there's beneficial relationships and
then the women's health research
um
in addition to the grant
securing our level grants and foundation
grants
the scholar group was also highly
productive in terms of
their number of publications and we're
actually continuing to research that in
terms of impact
in terms of mutual beneficial
relationships it was the principal
investigators the mentors the mentees um
all working together um
all working together to benefit one
another and one of the interesting
founding the findings we found as well
because we we interviewed the mentors
the mentors felt that they benefited
from their mentees in terms of looking
at research in a different way in a
different angle so we were very pleased
about that
in terms of institutional and broader
broader aspects the principal
investigators and others documented that
the visibility of the birch program
within their home institutions helped
them advance women's health research and
sex and gender research as well
and also allowed them to leverage for
new courses for other grants and so
forth so it was sort of a multiplicative
effect
of those
of the birch program being at their
institution
and it now brings me to with great
pleasure to introduce the moderator for
this sex and gender
um sex as a biological variable panel
judith regensteiner dr regensteiner is
one of the birch pis
and has been a long-term supporter and
innovator in terms of women's health
research and sex as a biological
variable sabv
as you can see here she holds a
professorship
of medicine in the division of general
internal medicine and cardiology at the
university of colorado
she also has an endowed chair of the
judith and joseph wagner endowed chair
in women's health
she's director in fact she created the
center for women's health research at
the university
she leads an interdisciplinary team
leads an interdisciplinary team having a
little trouble here um
there we go
there we go
i'm sorry for the technical difficulties
uh i want to thank dr clayton begg and
dutard and the office of research and
women's health
i'm honored to be moderating this
important panel sex as a biological
variable we will have three excellent
panelists speaking today doctors
virginia miller karen freund and khadir
tori i'm going to introduce them all now
and then their talks will follow after
the three talks with the question and
answer period
our first presentation will be from dr
virginia miller
the professor emeritus of surgery and
physiology at the mayo clinic
dr miller's research has included work
with experimental animals and clinical
studies focused on how sex steroids
steroids and conditions unique to women
that is pregnancy and menopause affect
cardiovascular health and cognition
dr miller has also played a key role in
innovative curriculum development on the
topic of sex as a biological variable
and this has made a difference in the
field
she has served as the principal
investigator of the mayo clinic building
interdisciplinary research careers in
women's health the birch program and of
the mayo clinic specialized center of
research excellence on sex differences
the score grant as well as director of
the mayo clinic women's health research
center from 2010 to 2010 to 2020.
she has authored over 250 original
publications and reviews her awards
include the bernadine healey award for
visionary leadership in women's health
women's day magazine uh red dress award
the paul m then hoda distinguished
litigatorship and vascular pharmacology
walter b cannon award from the american
physiological society
our second parent panelist will be dr
carol troyd dr
defront is the sarah murray jordan
professor of medicine at the tufts
university school of medicine and a vice
chair in the department of medicine at
tufts medical center she also holds a
harry and elsa giler american cancer
society clinical research professorship
she serves as co-principal investigator
of the tough spurge program and has
received local and national awards for
her work on career development
especially for women and
underrepresented women scientists
her research career has focused on
women's health with much of her work
specifically focused on health
disparities in women
internationally recognized for
patient navigation to reduce disparities
and on the impact of insurance reform on
care
her research portfolio includes work
funded through the office of research on
women's health to examine the factors
associated with the lack of career
progression of women especially women
from underrepresented
populations
and medical specifically in biomedical
careers
she and her colleagues have conducted
the only national longitudinal study of
medical school faculty in this regard
which and this work has demonstrated
that women continue to lag behind men in
career advancement and leadership even
accounting for their academic
achievements and she has outlined
specific institutional interventions
which may reverse these inequities
our final panelists will be dr khadir
dr torrey joined vanderbilt university
as a t-32 supported postdoctoral fellow
in 2015. he transitioned to a birch
scholar we are very proud of our birch
scholars those of us who are birch pis
in 2018.
as a birch scholar he was among three
scholars selected for oral presentation
at the national birch meeting last year
and he did an elegant and
um
eloquent proposal or talk rather about
his work
his research focus is on identifying and
understanding
phenotypes and other types of childhood
asthma and allergic diseases using a
multi-elements platform he integrates
infants and children's immune responses
and metabolomes to understand asthma and
allergic disease development including
the origin of sex differences in
allergic diseases
he was recently awarded a ko1 mentored
training grant so he's moved now he's
achieved his own individual k award
which is often the next step of a
successful birch scholar and will pursue
his goal of becoming an independent
investigators welcome doctors miller
fried and torrey
thank you dr regensteiner for that
introduction and for inviting me to
work with you on this important uh panel
today also thanks to the office of
research on women's health for
putting on this celebration to highlight
all their achievements over the last
thirty years
here are my disclosures
and during this short time i have with
you today i'd like to cover three
important topics
first of all i'd like to review for you
or lay the foundation for inclusion of
sex as a biological variable in research
i'd like to differentiate sex from
gender in translational research
and finally i'd like to identify
barriers and strategies for continued
success
so what is the foundation the foundation
is that a sex-based approach to research
is really the driver for developing a
holistic approach to patient-centered
care
and why is that well just to remind
everybody that every nucleated mammalian
cell in the human body that includes us
has
a sex that is it contains a group of sex
chromosomes the xx for female
and the x y for male
and although there may be some variation
in these um hormones or excuse me in
these chromosomes we know that the
presence of them in the nucleus really
directs
gene transcription and translation which
affects cell functions independent of
any hormones that might be present
this is a genomic effect and it is a sex
specific effect
however the sex chromosomes in addition
to influencing functions of the
autosomes also direct development of the
sex organs which are important for the
production of sex-specific hormones
primarily testosterone for males which
is then aromatized to an estrogen in
both males and females that estrogen of
course predominates in females
and these hormones can
diffuse into the cell
to bind to cellular receptors which
affect again nuclear transcription
but they also can bind to surface
receptors where their activity affects
ion channels
surface receptors which
initiate cell signaling mechanisms which
then may indirectly affect
genetic effects
but the
ion channels and the surface receptors
which do not
initiate direct genomic reaction
are called the genomic regulation of the
sex hormones
because of these sex hormones and sex
genes the chromosomes
in every cell of the body you can
understand that sex is a basic
biological variable
affecting all systems of the body
and is the basis for individualized
medicine
because there are sex specific
chromosomes and hormones then there are
sex differences in incidence prevalence
etiology symptomatology response to
treatment
morbidity and mortality from disease
but these aren't the only factors which
influence health and disease the
biological factors being male or female
of course are dictated by the genetics
the sex chromosomes and race of course
age and hormonal status which will vary
across the age and reproductive history
are biological factors which affect
health and disease
but we must also consider the
psychosocial factors which can
indirectly influence by all by the
biological factors
these are
factors which are considered as
components of gender and include things
like where you live the georec graphical
location the environmental exposures for
example if you are exposed to
certain levels of oxygen in the air dr
regensteiner is at high altitude on
practically at sea level here in
minnesota cultural expectations of how
we behave and restrictions in terms of
what we might be exposed to
family relationships which might
influence our level of stress
education which might influence our
income availability of health care and
of course our lifestyle whether we are
active what foods we eat whether we use
recreational drugs or alcohol smoking
and so on all can affect disease
therefore we have to consider the
interaction between the psychosocial
factors and biological factors by
accounting for these individual
or each of these
psychosocial factors to know to
where to intervene to
improve health
so once we have made these basic
discoveries we must incorporate those
concepts of the discovery into a
curriculum
but to do so we must consider the
components of such a curriculum
first of all we must include the basic
definitions of sex and gender
we have to review the control of the sex
chromosomes the hormonal effects on
cellular activities interactions of
hormonal activities with pharmaceutical
or
metabolic
components of drugs for
drug
hormone interactions
we need to include sex differences in
how we assess our study designs and
statistical analyses
expression of sex differences in health
and disease on a population level the
intersection of environmental and
psychosocial factors with biological
factors and how these influence health
disparities and actually there's
ethical implications of the
um how health care might be delivered
and of course right now there's a lot of
discussion around these issues in terms
of the coven vaccine how that might be
um distributed and we don't hear a lot
about sex differences we hear a lot
about racial differences and cycles and
sociological factors of where
individuals might be living or their age
sex though must be included in that
discussion somewhere along the line
once we have these concepts embedded
into curriculum we must develop
guidelines for how they're actually
going to be implemented in clinical
practice or research activities
and then to disseminate this information
into real world situations
and finally as i mentioned before public
health decisions and in the global
applications of sex and gender
through health
public health integration
although we have
achieved some success in these areas we
still
face three major barriers
the first is resources
the second is training and the third is
shifting agendas and political pressures
but let's look at some of the strategies
that have been implemented by the office
of research on women's health to
overcome these barriers
first of all resources
in 1991 bernardine healey was appointed
as the first woman director of the
national institutes of health and she
developed some targeted funding for
investigation into the effects of
estrogen on coronary artery disease i
was fortunate to receive one of these
one of six applications that were
successful for this initiative and this
really launched my career into more
study of hormones and sex specific
effects of hormones on the
cardiovascular system
we know and as a consequence of that
small
rfa or request for applications
there was a plethora of other studies
that weren't funded through that
initiative that continued to move
through nih study sections and really
brought about an explosion of
information about how hormones affect
cellular function during the 1990s
right now there are supplements to apply
for research for researchers to apply
for to include
both males and female animals or enrich
their populations of patients with men
or women to achieve an understanding to
be able to assess how sex influences the
particular area of study
in terms of training there have been
several successful initiatives
one is the specialized center of
research on sex differences now the
specialized centers of research
excellence on sex differences which
contains an educational or career
enhancement component
together with that and the building
interdisciplinary careers in women's
health
which is a competitive program initiated
by the office of research on women's
health to support
junior investigators
in the areas of women's health
will ensure that there are investigators
competent
to cons to study sex differences going
forward and also that the field will
flourish and expand
recently the office has initiated or
developed some educational modules which
are free on the internet which can be
used in a variety of uh educational
modalities um
in in classroom private study group
discussion and so on to really
enhance what we know
in a broader sense of scientists
physicians and even the general public
and how sex influences health and
disease
in terms of shifting agendas and
political pressures we all know from our
own experiences that even at our own
institutions the agendas may change in
terms of curriculum
access to materials how things are
delivered but we must must remain
vigilant
in terms of
pushing the idea that sex is a basic
biological component
at the fundamental levels of health and
disease
this not only has to happen at the
educational levels but also in the
research initiatives
having these initiatives that we've
already started we have to make sure
that they are sustained and sometimes
that requires
repeat visits to dean's repeat visits to
curriculum managers and educational
partnerships with individuals actually
developing or delivering the course
material
we must continue to partner with journal
editors to assure that research
has a it is the result that research
results are published for
each individual sex even if the study is
not powered to do a sex specific
analysis having the raw data available
enables
those data to be used in meta-analysis
and of course increases transparency
which would allow for the development of
new hypotheses in the future
we have to continue to educate the
public on the importance of
understanding sex as a biological
variable and really the difference
between sex and gender in terms of and
their interaction in terms of the
influence on health and disease
finally we have to continue to work with
lawmakers in terms of their
understanding i think the general public
of course but they are in a higher
position to really influence what we do
in terms of um
funding initiatives or actually
application of the data that might be
available we have to include them in a
huge
educational effort so that they
understand that sex is fundamental to
biology and research in the future
so over the past 30 years the office of
research of women's health has been
successful in a variety of initiatives
i congratulate them on these efforts
and wish them success as they move
forward in the future
thank you very much for your attention
and we will have questions during the
panel discussion
thank you very much judy it's really a
pleasure to be here today and i'm very
excited to be talking about mentoring as
a way to address sex as a biologic
variable in biomedical research
so why do i want to focus today on
mentorship as a way of ensuring that
junior faculty
are including sex differences in their
approaches
well i think this is really critical
especially at the stage of our early
stage investigators i think if they
learn the um the methods
and the reasoning behind including sex
differences in their research at their
early stages of their careers it's not
only going to improve their research but
it's going to give them the skills
for their future studies
i think it will also serve as they
become the mentors of the future to
reinforce
looking at sex differences in all
research
there are three aspects of mentorship
that i really want to consider in our
discussions today and hopefully
in our discussion period after these
presentations
one is the role of group and peer
mentorship
when thinking about sex differences
the second is the role of the inter
individual mentorship or the individual
mentors on the um scholars mentoring
team
and then the third is specifically
thinking about the biostatistical
mentorship
i'm going to end with some thoughts
about how we can move this forward
especially how we train our mentors in
order to have the skill set to do this
as part of their mentorship
so starting with group or peer
mentorship so most of our organizations
have some types of career development
programs for our birch scholars
and oftentimes these are
joint programs along with other k
awardees within our organizations or
other
junior faculty who are
aspiring to develop k
applications i think this is really a
great opportunity to introduce the
notion of sex's biologic variable to a
broad audience of investigators who may
have never really considered in their
research
it's a chance to really describe and
discuss with that audience the why of
sex is a biologic variable and to
provide examples of where their own
research may take a very different turn
or may
provide them with much much better
clarity on their findings if they look
specifically at sex differences
this is often an opportunity to provide
examples either through the research of
individuals in the group where to show
them what the possibilities might be
if they um begin to do their analysis
stratified by sex and start to really
understand um what the what the
possibilities are by by including sex
um differences in their research and in
their analyses
secondly i wanted to focus on individual
mentorship
so all of our scholars have mentoring
teams and i believe that each a mentor
within that mentoring team
can assist
in including sex differences into the
research
it may start with looking at the premise
of the research and the background
looking for possible sex differences
that are known
thinking about how to include both sexes
in the methods design and then how to
design the analysis to address sex
differences
i think there's a particular
role to play for the biostatistical
mentors in helping look at sex
differences
i oftentimes when bringing up the topic
of sex as a biologic variable and asking
junior faculty how they are how they are
accounting for sex as a biologic
variable the answer i frequently get is
well we've um adjusted for sex as a
covariate so i think if if there's one
thing we could do it is um
train everyone to know that adjusting
for sex as a covariate is really not
analogous to looking at sex as a
biologic variable and really
understanding if there are sex
differences in the analysis
so biostatistical mentors can be really
helpful in understanding the role of
both exploratory analyses where there
may not be power um and it may be
looking at the data without statistical
analysis for
possible
signals that there may be a sex
difference as opposed to having a sex
specific um hypothesis that requires
confirmatory analysis and requires an
adequate power calculation to ensure
that that confirmatory analysis is
powered to look for a result
i think it requires um that by our bios
as biostatistical mentors
understand the various analytic methods
that can be used to address sex
differences
so how do we advance sex differences in
research through mentorship well i think
this is going to involve mentor training
i think many of our mentors themselves
are unclear on how to include sex as a
biologic variable into research design
and into analysis so i think it requires
that
those of us that have mentor training
programs consider adding this as a
component in future mentor training
programs
i think there's also a need to consider
training study sections so that there's
uniformity in how study sections apply
the regulation and the rules around sex
differences
in biomedical research so that our
junior faculty
can know what to expect when their
grants are reviewed and can adequately
prepare
strong
sex of biologic variable analysis
analysis plans to address that
i think there needs to be a specific
focus
from our biostatistical consultants and
colleagues
to put this focus into the
biostatistical support that our junior
faculty receive
so i'm looking forward to continuing our
discussion today i want to thank the
office of research um in women's health
for 30 great years of support thank you
very much
hello
my name is kiritori from vanderbilt
university
i'm a bridge scholar
today i'll be sharing my perspective on
adopting sex as biological variable in
research
to outline my talk
i will briefly discuss my experience as
bridge scholar
then highlight my approach in
incorporating sex as political variable
in my research
before joining british scholar my
knowledge on why and how to incorporate
sex as political variable in research
was very limited
i have learned a lot during the
application process and also
during my tenure as speech scholar
as was a requirement to have a research
proposal to incorporate sex as political
variable and address
sex differences in the pathogenesis of
disease
the application process talks me a lot
i was fortunate enough to join a
community of multidisciplinary bridge
scholars who helped in the learning
process
these include
previous scholars serving as mentors for
color current words
our group met every week to peer review
carer development topics
manuscripts and grant applications for
scholars
this process ensured that
sexas biological variable is
sufficiently incorporated and sex
differences in the pathogenesis of
disease were adequately considered
my area of investigation is asthma
so the reminder of the talk
i will provide examples on how i
approach sex as political available in
asthma research
as my the chronic disease that affects
about 339 million people around the
world
in the usa number is 25 million and
still increasing
there are recognized sex differences in
asthma incidents and morbidity
across this lifespan
which makes asthma a natural effect to
study sex differences
this figure comes from cdc
and it shows the prevalence of asthma by
sex in age groups
blue bars are for male
and yellow ones are for female
as you can see from the figure during
childhood asthma prevalence was higher
among male children
and the prevalence switched around
poverty
in attitude the prevalence of asthma was
high among women compared to men
since the switch is around poverty
the usual suspects for
sex difference in asthma are sex
hormones
this prompts
us and others to investigate
relationship between sex hormones and
risk of asthma to explain the sex
differences
using publicly available enhanced data
this study assessed the association
between testosterone and order of asthma
stratified by age group and sex
as you can see from the figure
where the x-axis or ratio
and y-axis show stratification groups
in male
and female
young
age group
it is not significant but increasing
total testosterone seem to increase the
order of asthma
in
male
and female adult group
increase in total testosterone seem to
increase the order of asthma
but it's all only significant in female
adults
even though testosterone is associated
with autophasma
in adult female
we are not able to show that
testosterone is responsible for sex
differences in asthma prevalence
in fact what we see from this estimation
is
the directionality of the estimate
indicate that differential association
between
a child group and adult group
are in the association
asthma pathogenesis likely begin with
neutral
and early life exposures
in preschool child group
asthma is indistinguishable from viral
whis
as you can see from the figure
in preschool group
wheels prevalence is higher among male
children
childhood exposure to respiratory virus
and consequent response of
immune system are strongly associated
with the development of asthma
uh
sex as biological variable affects pose
the function of immune system
and weeds
so we asked if sex difference immune
response
to respiratory viral infection could
explain the sex differences in childhood
with in subsequent development of asthma
to study this we used inspire called
which is a bird's cold
established in middle tennessee
surveillance was conducted for
respiratory infection
uh during the first year of uh infants
uh well uh winter period
we conducted
surveillance every two weeks
when the children were sick with a
respiratory infection
we took nasal wash
samples
and we are saying that those another
watch samples for 53 cytokines
chemokines and gross fibers
growth factors
using multiplex assays
we also
i say using qpcr to detect rsv
in the samples
we followed the children from one year
to four years every year using
questionary to assess with frequency
we took
the high dimensional data
and analyzed
uh
by satisfying by sex
as you can see we have 167 ml
in the sample
and 131 female in the sample
we use the hybrid of supervised and
unsupervised clustering approach to
identify three distinct immune
response clusters in both male and
female
without going into detail
the identified clusters
were characterized as follows
1
is dominated by type 2 immune response
in cluster 2
shows generally subdued immune response
and cluster 3
is dominated by type 1 immune response
the immune response clusters were
generally similar between males and
females except for slight differences in
the detail
then
we took the identified clusters and used
generalized estimated education to
assess
association between the identifying
clusters
and
with the current weighs from one year to
four year recurrence with here is
defined as
more than two wheezing epsilon per year
the x-axis of the forest plate shows the
adjusted all ratio
y-axis shows the clusters
the comparison group here is cluster
three
so compared to cluster
cluster 2 and cluster 1 are
significantly associated with increased
wheeze in female
a similar analysis in male
the directionality are
similar with female
but not statistically significant
what we can conclude from this study is
that
even though
generally prevalence of whis is higher
in bodies
type 2 dominated immune response to
respiratory infection
causes greater risk of
a childhood with in girls
to summarize my talk
as bridge scholar i have been fortunate
enough to be mentored by
an interdisciplinary community of
investigators
and be able to adopt sex as political
variable in my research
asthma prevalence has known sexual
dimorphism which changes during
childhood with a switch around poverty
and that makes it suitable to study sex
differences
understanding the underlying biological
and environmental reason for sex
differences in asthma incidence and
morbidity is an ongoing effort
my approach to this problem include
using sex stratified high dimensional
molecular data to understand the
upstream pathways driving disease during
of
disease origin and explaining the
heterogeneity of asthma
with this i would like to acknowledge my
funding sources
my prime mentor
tina hart which who directs the
center for asthma research at vanderbilt
vanderbilt bridge leadership
rpi
katherine
hershman
and co-directors digna edwards and amy
myers
and
bridge scholars at vanderbilt who really
provided great feedback
both scientifically and career-wise
thank you very much
and i look forward to the questions and
discussions
hi everyone it's uh judy ray steiner
again from
from colorado
and i am
here to write the question and answer
session i want to thank my colleagues dr
miller wright and trury for their
excellent
i thought they were
protected so much
so i want to start with a question
and then the others can answer as well
i wanted to ask you virginia what is the
adoption of and biological
variable thinking at the mayo
clinic and i know that you're a
innovative leader in curriculum
development as you are also in research
kitchen going for
speaking around
well i have lost my visuals and i hope
you can hear me can you hear me
i can hear you fine okay thank you um
well it's and i and i think that this is
probably typical of many
um institutions that we've seen some
success with incorporating sex as a
biological variable into some aspects of
the curriculum however we have yet to be
able to develop a um
a standard curriculum into
the medical school which would
incorporate these concepts into each of
the individual blocks our biggest
success has been with the ccats program
the clinical
science translational program
where we have actually series of
lectures and workshops on these on these
concepts and we've also developed some
course material within the epidemiology
classes or the coursework that has
incorporated the statistical analysis
into
population studies as well as
is in the design
of basic science studies our other major
initiative has really been to educate
researchers in terms of how to account
for sex as a biological variable in
their research grants we started some
workshops about three or four years ago
and those have been very successful in
terms of
individuals bringing their grants to the
workshop where we
hammer these concepts out in person look
at the individual grants and talk about
how they can incorporate the concept not
only to fill out some questionnaire or
block as how sex is important but really
to put it through the whole thought
process of what
and this has been i guess modeled at
other places and we've had inquiries
from um
at uh cedar sinai one of the other
school programs and the emory birch
program has picked this up with a
one-day workshop as well so the
individual efforts uh remain like i say
you have to keep at it otherwise
people lose attention to the next bright
shiny thing that happens down the road
sex is a biological variable isn't a
bright shiny thing that'll go away it is
so basic it is the bedrock of what we
must work from
i completely agree dr finder dr torrey i
can't see you but would you like to
respond to that question as well or
shall i move on
the one additional comment i might add
is
that
you can hear me okay
um
the one additional comment i might add
is i is i think there um still has been
some um variability in how
the nih study sections are
um are reviewing grants around their use
of such as a biologic variable and i
think that um
i think one of the one of the possible
ways of moving this forward at each
institution is to assure that there is
some standardization in grant reviews um
i think there's nothing like knowing
that your grants are going to be
reviewed to motivate investigators and
organizations to really have robust
curriculum to train and robust uh um
review of grant submissions uh to ensure
that they're accounting for this so i
think there are our real needs and i
think there are real opportunities at
our individual organizations to develop
this curriculum um but i think it also
can be um can be moved uh further um
maybe faster um by implementation of
what we already have as guidelines um
in our nih grants
to do
to include sex as a biologic variable
where appropriate
and if i can add to that
can i just add to that a little bit judy
um you may be thinking this too i mean
you brought up a good point
accountability in terms of of the study
sections is one thing but i think we
also need to
hold accountable individuals who get
these supplements and who are
getting nih grants that they actually
report their data on the sex differences
and so that's a piece that i think can
be strengthened moving forward is
accountability and once that
accountability moves forward in terms of
getting the data into the literature i
think it's going to be easier to
see
the curriculum develop as a consequence
of that because there's going to be a
natural sort of waterfall effect if you
have the information in the literature
and it gets in and it's
always asked for and it gets into
clinical guidelines it's going to have
to go backwards into the medical
curriculum for sure
and with questions on the um
exams in terms of licensing exams
that'll facilitate it it's a little
tougher on the basic science end and
that's why the accountability in the
research grants and the publications is
so important because it's easy for that
material to slip through the rocks
because
let's look through the cracks because
there's no ultimate outcome immediately
in some of the basic science studies
into patient-directed care
i agree with both of you we are working
on curriculum
at the university of colorado's medicine
which we're going to give to our
scholars are going to be required to
take it and um
it involves they already do have a
required curriculum all our scientists
at central and health research are
taking curriculum that includes elements
of training and academic skills career
development skills and now we're going
to really incorporate the new sabv
primer that nih
put out
weeks ago and i encourage everybody
listening to look for this primer it's
amazing and really does help with
describing how to incorporate sex as a
biological variable into training which
is going to be critical to change the
paradigm
of uh thinking about one sex at a time
or male sex
so please look at that
and i think that's critical too in terms
of educating the educator educators that
you know once
we know certain fundamental things and
many individuals who may be facilitating
a course are ringing their hands saying
where are the materials so if we can now
give them really good source materials
that things don't have to be created de
novo each time a curriculum is developed
it'll facilitate these ideas and that
that group of um modules from um
nih is is wonderful and really will help
facilitate that but we have to be sort
of disseminators of that within our own
institutions because people aren't
necessarily
aware of it
um
dr friend i want to direct this question
to you first
you know one of the things that i've
thought about a lot is our junior you
know our scholars junior faculty maybe
early adopters of sex is a biological
variable but how do we work with older
mentors
not saying senior that word is never
popular but saying
people that are you know more
established in the field that
haven't brought their whole career how
do we change their thinking and how do
we help them help
younger people i think yeah so judy i
think it's a great question about how do
we move experienced investigators who
may have not really developed their
research um to include sex as a biologic
variable especially if they're serving
as the mentors for the next generation
i think there are a couple of things
that i can think of that might be
helpful so um so first of all mentors
are not born they are really trained and
i think there's really good literature
now to suggest that we can train
individuals to be good mentors they
don't have to sort of somehow be born
with this innate um ability um to uh um
to help other people do research um so
there's really uh and and um we have
found that in almost all the training
grants that we submit through our
organization when we include specific
mentor training as part of that
training grant it receives really good
scores um reviewers like the notion that
we are actively training mentors and so
you know i think that for all birch
applications for example um there should
be a component about training mentors on
how to mentor around sex as a biologic
variable and hopefully would that that
could then be expanded to all
training programs because this is one of
the key components of an nih brand um in
just the same way that we're training on
rigor and reproducibility and we're
training on premise um this is one of
the key components so i think that
developing that expectation
uh the training grants have mentoring
programs um and mentor training built
into them and that mentor training
includes sex as a biologic variable
would be one way to very quickly move
the move the dow forward for all of our
programs
that's great it's
this is such an exciting discussion that
you know all of it that i
of course i love this area uh dr miller
do you want to comment further on the
idea of getting the more you are you
know we are more
senior i'll use that hated word but
we are passionate about mentoring and
changing to work at sabb but how do we
get this out there how do you see that
happening
the the more established investigators
we have struggled with and the best way
to get to them there's not they're not
going to come to a training program okay
um they're not going to sit down for an
hour we have tried to think about more
creative ways and i know at university
of kentucky they start doing things
around the lunch time where they invite
people the mentors to lunch and sort of
talk about these concepts and that might
work but now we're in this virtual
environment so good luck with that
i think one of the things that we can
push is an indirect way
we have interaction with the scholars
and at mayo we're pretty um scholar
focused and we're pretty hands-on with
these scholars
and if we incur if we require them to do
this train this material and require
them to have their
um research directed towards a sex
difference that's going to trickle up
maybe
um
to to their mentor and we have reached
several mentors that way individuals who
were very reluctant who are now uh and
these are major senior people are now
now writing um major review articles
looking at their own literature from a
sex
uh
specific point of view so i think
there's not one approach is going to
take all you know somebody came to me in
my last year or so of working and told
me i had to go to a mentoring class you
know i mean my eyes would roll
and um and i'm sure there are many other
investigators in my position don't make
me do one more thing you know so i think
we have to take a multi-prong approach
to how to get investigators at all
levels engaged and i think we have to
think of their career stage their age
and of course their uh gender in terms
of what might work best for them
that's a great discussion
i'm sorry karen
i was just gonna i was just gonna
comment on on
your um your comment about whether you
can get uh mentors to training i the one
approach that we've used that actually
has been um uh successful is mentors
really don't have a chance to talk about
their experience as mentoring um and
both the pitfalls what's worked well and
we've done a
flipped classroom approach so we've
given them some materials to look at
beforehand and we really use the time
together for discussion and and to my
surprise um the reviews we've gotten
when we've done that is that the
sessions were too short um so that makes
me think that uh that the sessions were
probably just the right length uh
because otherwise it'd be too long um
so uh i wouldn't completely i i do
understand the the the challenges of of
all the different uh competing uh
demands on people's time so i wouldn't
completely give up on uh on getting
mentors together to want to talk about
mentoring
perhaps you could share some of those
materials
yeah and we've you know we've used many
of the materials that are on
the national um um uh mentoring i'm
liking on the nrmn's full name i just
can remember the acronym but we've used
the materials that are on that website
on mentoring and can provide those
materials later in the
in the discussion
great great
um i think that's points out one of the
key things amongst birch
pis and other people interested in
women's health is the
collaborative nature of the interactions
is just wonderful and we all learn very
much from each other
dr tory i want to direct a question in
your direction
nih initiatives have greatly contributed
to bringing successful biological
variable
thinking to the fore
and have brought that thinking to
research what do you see as a next step
or a next step
i i think that's a
a great um question and
so so uh especially for uh junior
investigators like me who are just
starting to uh navigate the
nih system
and learning um
how
innate policy applies uh in terms of
success political variable
is is a great way of studying but still
in this regard it's a long way to go in
the scientific arena that you know um
the approach to sex house variable
um
is still um not investigated enough
people like me can make a care out of it
um
and drive these
in terms of methodological development
how to incorporate success political
variable into research and expanding in
that area
in bioinformatics and
in um
you know using this
high dimensional data to group with a
sex political variable also um
developing biostatistical method that
incorporates this
concept into
every research possible that that we see
sexual differences in the
pathogenesis of disease
that's great um
what what else would you like to add
doctors miller and freund
we've talked already about
how to increase
and
you know make sure that mentoring is
available at all levels we've talked
about curriculum what else do we need to
do
go ahead karen
well i was just going to mention that
there was one comment in the in the
questions about the role of journals um
and making sure that that uh holding our
journal editors accountable to um to
including uh sex differences in in
manuscripts um and not um and not just
delegating you know the sex differences
to the supplements but really um
requiring it you know if if the nih is
requiring that we collect this data and
report report on this data um there's a
need to really push at journal editors
as well
virginia you were going to say something
as well
well i was just going to say in terms of
sort of the concept of mentoring you
know our
our scholars have a mentoring team but
when we talk to our scholars we think we
want to encourage them to look at
individuals beyond
their mentoring team in terms of what
they can learn from them you don't have
to have a formalized mentor
in order to have an influence on your
career you can look at other
investigators whom you admire or who are
leaders in your particular scientific
topic
and emulate what they do what is it
about them that makes you
admire them or want to be like them
and the kind of questions that you ask
yourself in terms of what are my
strengths
what are my weaknesses and where do i
need to develop them
so we have developed kind of a
checklist for individuals when they
first come into the program in terms of
certain characteristics of where they
feel that they are on a scale
there's no grade for this this is
something that they can track
where they feel their weaknesses are in
terms of manuscript writing or
presentation or
whatever and every time we meet with
them during the year of the program
we bring that checklist up and see and
hold them accountable to what actually
they're doing
proactively to
correct what deficits they identify with
them within themselves
so it's a dynamic process it's not just
the mentor doing something to the mentee
it's an active engagement but we it's
only successful
if the mentee wants to be mentored you
know
we've had many
things that you can you know spend hours
with them and then they go away and it's
like really where what has happened you
know so um
there's accountability on both sides and
i think you know having looking at other
individuals other than your mentoring
team sometimes can be very beneficial in
terms of uh uh activity in your career
and even reaching out to individuals at
other institutions we've had several
birth scholars do that
um
from when we used to go to meetings and
they end up being a co-mentor or
whatever
or to go to their laboratory for
additional training so there's a
proactive piece on this in terms of the
mentee that is i think also critical
what we're talking about the acceptance
of journals
is not a foregone conclusion and in fact
it's still somewhat of an uphill battle
a lot of journals still do not
disaggregate results in their report
make authors disaggregate their results
there are a lot of journals where you
can still read an article where you
don't know the sex of the animals being
studied there are many instances so that
issue is still a very much uh an issue
facing us
and the other issues are still there
what's exciting is now that there are
beginning to be materials by which we
can combat
the lack of attention to sex differences
so
things are changing
i think
in terms of the journals i like to
always challenge the audience is that
this is something they can fix
because we all review papers and i'll
tell you what if i get a paper and i
just got one today
that uh you know i still
review papers if i think they're
interesting and i can make an impact and
i can just read through the abstract
they tell me how many men and women they
have and then go off to give me the
group to results on drug drug
interactions never segregating them by
sex and that's to me is unacceptable and
that's going to go back with major
revision so as a reviewer you have quite
a bit of influence in terms of what the
ultimate publication will be
and we all can do that that's not
that hard
grant review also allows you the
opportunity to make sure that if proper
attention is paid for such issues
well we are running a little short on
time or we still have a few more minutes
though um
any thoughts
to how about each person give their
final thoughts to this discussion uh
virginia
well i just want to say that this has
been an honor for me to participate in
this workshop um if it hadn't have been
for that grant i initially got through
under bernadine healey's leadership i
probably wouldn't be on this stage today
so really emphasize the effect of how
providing
resources especially financial resources
for this topic goes a long way
and
it's been a pleasure over my years to
work with this area i never thought i
would be in it and this is a good
example of
you know how you take opportunities and
really build a career so thanks to
everybody it's been a pleasure working
with you over the years i do wish the
office of research and women's health
continued success i'm sure they will be
uh
dr frank
yeah thank you thank you again to orwh
for this great um uh put together this
great uh symposium uh you know during
these challenging times it's i know we
would have all loved to been together
but it's great to see see
our colleagues here on the screen and to
learn about the work and you know i
think that i'll just end by saying i
think dr tory's um presentation was
really a great example and compilation
of everything we talked about when you
started by talking about working with
your peer mentors who gave you a lot of
guidance starting with the submission
process and talking about about the
various roles of the mentors within your
interdisciplinary mentoring team it was
really a perfect example and and uh with
asthma being so common um it is uh is
interesting that we've not had more work
done to really understand the sex
differences in asthma so i want to
congratulate you on your work and and
wish you good luck with your with your
ko1 thank you very much also dr tory
because
birch scholars are really the workforce
of the future none of our work on
women's health or health of women or sex
differences is going to happen without
you know exciting young investigators
like you so
thank you for the work you're pursuing
and i for one am really glad to have
people so interested in this area what
would you like to say dr tory as your
final
really thank you very much for inviting
me it's really to give my perspective
possibly scholar um thank you very much
uh for ow
h and
for bridge also for preaching
my you know setting my
character trajectory uh this way and
then you know
transition me to a k
or one which really is very helpful and
also i'm very thankful to all
bridge leadership was in at vanderbilt
and also at the
um on nh levels
who really
provided great advisors all during these
times and i appreciate it
and i'm looking forward to work on this
area as much as uh
possible in the future
thank you well thank you all
i really appreciate your participation
and i again thank nih for putting on
this wonderful panel i found it so
excellent learned through the putting on
of it and i want to thank everyone and
again thanks to doctors clayton begg and
duterte for their hard work on it
and thanks everybody and
have a good day